As part of Mit core six zero,
nine,
nine artificial general intelligence,
I've gotten the chance to sit down with
Max tegmark.
He is a professor he hit on my tea,
is a physicist,
spent a large part of his career
studying the mysteries of our
cosmological universe,
but he's also studied in,
delved into the beneficial possibilities
and the existential risks of artificial
intelligence amongst many other things.
He's the cofounder of the future of Life
Institute,
author of two books,
both of which I highly recommend.
First our mathematical universe.
Second is life,
three point zero.
He's truly an out of the box thinker and
a fun personality,
so I really enjoyed talking to him.
If you'd like to see more of these
videos in the future,
please subscribe and also click the
little bell icon to make sure you don't
miss any videos.
Also,
twitter,
linkedin,
Agi.mit.edu.
If you want to watch other lectures,
are conversations like this one better
yet?
Go read Max's book,
light.
Three point zero.
Chapter seven on goals is my favorite.
It's really more philosophy and
engineering come together and it opens
with a quote by dusty.
See,
the mystery of human existence lies not
in just staying alive,
but in finding something to live for.
Lastly,
I believe that every failure rewards us
with an opportunity to learn and that
sense.
I've been very fortunate to fail and so
many new and exciting ways and,
uh,
this conversation was no different.
I've learned about something called
radio frequency interference,
RFI.
Look it up.
Apparently music and conversations,
some local radio stations can bleed into
the audio that we're recording in such a
way that almost completely ruins that
audio.
It's an exceptionally difficult sound
source to remove,
so I've gotten the opportunity to learn
how to avoid rfi in the future.
During the recording sessions have also
gotten the opportunity to learn how to
use adobe audition and isotope rx six to
do some noise,
some audio repair.
Of course,
this is exceptionally difficult noise to
remove.
I am an engineer.
I'm not an audio engineer.
Neither is anybody else in our group,
but would a best.
Nevertheless,
I thank you for your patience and I hope
you're still able to enjoy this
conversation.
Do you think there's intelligent life
out there in the universe?
Let's open up with an easy question.
I have a minority view here.
Actually,
when I give public lectures,
I often ask for a show of hands who
thinks there's intelligent life out
there somewhere else and almost everyone
put their hands up and when I ask why,
they'll be like,
oh,
there's so many galaxies out there.
There's gonna be.
But I'm a numbers nerd.
Right?
So when you look more carefully at it,
it's not so clear at all the.
When we talk about our universe,
first of all,
we don't mean all of space.
Do we actually mean I don't know.
You can throw me in the university.
She wants to behind you there.
It's,
we'd simply mean the spherical region of
space from which light has to reach us.
So far during the 14 point 8 billion
year,
13 point 8 billion years since our big
bang,
there's more space here,
but this is what we call a universe
because that's all we have access to.
So is there intelligent life here that's
gotten to the point of building
telescopes and computers?
My guess is no,
actually that the probability of it
happening on it,
any given planet,
there's some number we don't know what
it is and what we do know is that the
number can be super high because there's
over a billion earth like planets in the
mill keyway,
galaxy alone,
many of which are billions of years
older than earth.
And um,
aside from some of you will for
believers,
you know,
there isn't much evidence that any
superintendent civilization has come
here at all.
And so that's the famous Fermi paradox.
Right?
And then if you,
if you work the numbers,
what you find is that the,
if you have no clue what the probability
is of getting life on a given planet.
So it could be 10 to the minus 10 to the
minus 20 or temperament is to any power
of 10 is sort of equally likely if you
want to be really open minded,
that translates into it being equally
likely that our nearest neighbor is 10
to the 16 meters away,
tend to the 70 meters away and of 18
don't.
By the time he gets much less than 10,
16 already,
we pretty much.
No,
there is nothing else that's close.
And when you get the opposite would have
discovered us.
Yeah,
they would have been discovered as long
ago or if they're really close,
we would have probably noted some
engineering projects that they're doing
and if it's beyond 10 to 26 meters
that's already outside of here.
So my guess is actually that there are,
we are the only life in here.
They've gotten to the point of building
advanced tech,
which I think is,
is very,
um,
puts a lot of responsibility on our
shoulders not screw up.
You know,
I think actually people who take for
granted that it's okay for us to screw
up,
have an accidental nuclear war or go
extinct somehow because there's a sort
of star trek like situation out there
with some other life forms are going to
come and bail us out.
And it doesn't matter as much.
I think allowing us into a false sense
of security.
I think it's much more prudent to say,
you know,
let's be really grateful for this
amazing opportunity we've had.
And um,
makes the best of it just in case it is
down to us.
So from a physics perspective,
do you think intelligent life says
unique from a sort of statistical view
of the size of the universe,
but from the basic matter of the
universe,
how difficult is it for intelligent
life to come about?
Was the kind of advanced tech building
life is implied in your statement that
it's really difficult to create
something like a human species?
I think what we know is that going from
no life to having life that can do
archive level of tech,
there was some sort of to going beyond
that.
Then it actually settling our whole
universe with life.
There's some road major roadblock there
which is some great filter as um,
it's sometimes called the which,
which is tough to get through.
It's either that roadblock is either be
behind us or in front of us.
Right?
I'm hoping very much that it's behind
us.
I'm,
I'm super excited.
Every time we get a new report from NASA
saying they failed to find any life on
Mars,
like yes,
because that suggests that the hard
part.
Maybe what maybe it was getting the
first right Bozon or or something.
Some very low level kind of stepping
stone,
so they were home free because if that's
true,
then the future is really only limited
by our own imagination.
It would be much suckier if it turns out
that this level of life is kind of a
diamond dozen,
but maybe there's some other problem,
like as soon as a civilization gets
advanced technology within 100 years,
they get into some stupid fight with
themselves and poof.
Yep.
That would be a bummer.
Yeah.
So
you've explored the mysteries of the
universe of the cosmological universe,
the one that's sitting
between us today.
I think you've also have begun to
explore
the other universe,
which is sort of the mystery,
the mysterious universe of the mind of
intelligence,
of intelligent life.
So is there a common thread between your
interests are in the way you think about
space and intelligence?
Oh yeah.
When I was a teenager I was already very
fascinated by the biggest questions and
I felt that the two biggest mysteries of
all in science where our universe out
there and our universe in here.
Yup.
So it's quite natural after having spent
quarter of a century on my career,
thinking a lot about this one,
I'm now indulging in the luxury of doing
research on this one.
It's just so cool.
I feel the time is ripe now.
Refer you directly.
Deepening our understanding of this to
start exploring this one.
Yeah,
because I think I think a lot of people
view intelligence as something
mysterious that can only exist in
biological organisms like us and
therefor dismiss all.
Talk about artificial general
intelligence is science fiction,
but from my perspective as a physicist,
you know I am a blob of corks and
electrons moving around in a certain
pattern and process the information in
certain ways and this is also a blob of
quirks that electrons.
I'm not smarter than the water because I
made a different kind of works.
Right?
I made up quirks and down quirks.
Exact same kind as this.
It's A.
There's no secret sauce.
I think in me it's all about the pattern
of the information processing and this
means that there's no law of physics
saying that we can't create technology
which can help us by being incredibly
intelligent than help us crack Mr.
so we couldn't.
In other words,
I think we've really only seen the tip
of,
of intelligence iceberg so far.
Yeah.
So the perceptronium yeah.
Uh,
so you current coin this amazing term as
a hypothetical state of matter sort of
thinking from a physics perspective,
what is the kind of matter that can
help,
as you're saying a subjective
experience,
emerge?
Consciousness emerge.
So how do you think about consciousness
from this physics perspective?
Very good question.
So again,
I'm.
No,
I think
many people have underestimated our
ability to make progress on this by
convincing themselves it's hopeless
because somehow we're missing some
ingredients that we need.
There's some new consciousness,
part it go or whatever.
I happened to think that we're not
missing anything and that it's not.
The interesting thing about
consciousness that gives us this amazing
subjective experience of colors and
sounds and emotions on is rather
something at the higher level about the
patterns of information processing and
that's why I.
that's why I am like thinking about this
idea of perceptronium.
What does it mean for an arbitrary
physical system to be conscious in terms
of what it's particle to do anything or,
or,
or it's inflammation is doing.
I don't think.
I don't.
I hate the carbon chauvinism.
You know,
this attitude.
You have to be made of carbon atoms to
be smart or conscious.
Something about the information
processing kind of matter performs.
Yeah.
And you know,
you can see I have my favorite equations
here describing various fundamental
aspects of the world.
I feel that I think one day maybe
someone is watching this or come up with
the equations that information
processing has to satisfy to be
consciously.
I'm quite convinced there is big
discovery to be made there because let's
face it,
some sometimes we know that some
information processing is conscious
because we are conscious,
but we also know that a lot of
information processing is not conscious.
Like most of the information presently
happening in your brain right now is not
conscious.
They like 10 megabytes per second coming
in even just through your visual system
and you are not conscious about your
heartbeat regulation or,
or most things,
right?
Uh,
even,
even like if I just ask you to read what
it says here,
you look at it and then,
oh,
now you know what it said,
but you're not aware of how the
computation actually happened.
You're like,
to your consciousness is like the that
got an email at the end with a final
answer.
So what is it that makes a difference?
I think that's both those great science
mystery.
We're actually studying it a little bit
in my lab here at mit a.
But I also think it's just a really
urgent question answer for starters.
I mean,
if you're an emergency room doctor and
you have an unresponsive patient coming
in,
wouldn't it be great if in addition to
having
a ct scanner,
you,
you had a conscience of scanner that you
figure out whether this person is
actually having locked in syndrome,
right?
Whereas actually comatose,
uh,
and in the future,
imagine if we build the robots or the
machine that
we could have really good conversations
with students.
I think it's very,
very likely to happen.
Right?
Wouldn't you want to know,
like if you're a home health,
a robot is actually experiencing
anything or just like a Zombie,
I mean,
would you prefer.
What would you prefer?
Would you prefer that it's actually
unconscious so that you don't have to
feel guilty about switching it off or
giving boring chores or what would you
prefer?
Well,
the certainly would,
we would prefer,
I would prefer the appearance of
consciousness,
but the question is whether the
appearance of cautiousness is different
than cost consciousness itself.
And sort of ask that as a question,
do you think we need to,
you know,
understand what consciousness is,
solve the hard problem of consciousness
in order to build something,
a light in a GI system?
No,
I don't think that.
I think we will probably be able to
build things even if we don't answer
that question,
but if we want to make sure that what
happens is a good thing,
we better solve it first.
So it's a wonderful controversy you're
raising there where you have basically
three points of view about the hard
problems.
So there are two different points of
view that both conclude that the hard
problem of crunches is bs.
Do you have,
on one hand you have some people like
Daniel Dennett who say this is
unconscious is just bs because
consciousness is the same thing as
intelligence.
There's no difference.
So anything which acts conscious is
conscious dislike,
like we are.
And then there are also a lot of people,
including many top ai researchers.
I know you say,
Oh,
I have a consciousness is just bullshit.
Because of course machines can never be
conscious,
right?
They're always going to.
It's going to be zombies,
never have to feel guilty about how you
treat them
and then there's a third group of people
including Giulio Tononi for example,
and another here's the cochrane number
of others.
I would put myself on this middle camp
who say that actually some information
processing is conscious and some is not,
so let's find the equation which can be
used to determine which it is and I
think we've just been a little bit lazy
kind of running away from this problem
for a long time.
It's been almost taboo.
Even mentioned the c word,
a lot of circles because.
But we should stop making excuses.
This is a science question and there are
ways we can even test test any scenario
that makes predictions for this.
And coming back to this health a robot.
I mean,
so you said you would want your help a
robot to certainly conscious and treat
you like to have conversations with you
and I think so wouldn't you?
Would you feel,
would you feel a little bit creeped out
if you realize that it was just glossed
up the tape recorder?
You know,
there was this Zombie and faking
emotion.
Would you prefer that it actually had an
experience or what would you prefer that
it's actually not experiencing anything,
so you feel you don't have to feel
guilty about what you do to it.
It's such a difficult question because,
uh,
you know,
it's like when you're in a relationship
and you say,
well,
I love you and the other person will
love you back.
It's like asking or do they really love
you back or are they just saying they
love you back?
Uh,
do you,
don't you really want them to actually
love you?
It's hard to.
It's hard to really know the difference
between a everything seeming like
there's consciousness present,
there's intelligence president,
there's a affection,
passion,
love,
and,
and it actually being there.
I'm not sure.
Do you have,
like,
do you ask,
you can ask a question to make it a bit
more point.
That's a mass general hospital is right
across the river,
right?
Yes.
Suppose,
I suppose you're going in for a medical
procedure and they're like,
you know,
uh,
for,
for anesthesia,
what we're going to do is we're gonna
give you a muscle relaxant so you won't
be able to move a and you're gonna feel
excruciating pain during the whole
surgery,
but you won't be able to do anything
about it.
But then we're going to give you this
drug that race is your memory of it.
Would you be cool about that?
What's the difference that you're
conscious about it or not?
If,
if,
if there's no behavioral change.
Right,
right.
That's a really interesting.
That's a really clear where to put it.
That's.
Yeah,
it feels like in that sense,
experiencing it as a valuable quality.
So actually being able to have
subjective experiences,
at least in that case is,
is valuable.
And I think we humans have a little bit
of a bad track record also of making
these selfserving arguments that other
entities aren't conscious.
You know,
people often say,
oh,
these animals can't feel pain.
Right.
It's okay to boil lobster is because we
asked them if it hurt and I didn't say
anything.
And now that was just the paper out
saying lobsters did do feel pain when
you boil them lemon,
they're banning it in Switzerland and,
and,
and we did this with slaves too often
and say,
oh,
they don't mind a bit on maybe
unconscious or women don't have souls or
whatever.
So I'm a little bit nervous when I hear
people just take as an axiom that
machines can't have experience ever.
I think this is just this really
fascinating science question is what it
is.
Yeah,
let's research it and try to figure out
what it is that makes the difference
between unconscious intelligent behavior
and conscious intelligent behavior.
So in terms of,
if you think about Boston dynamics,
humanoid robot being sort of a,
with a broom being pushed around the
it's starts is,
it starts pushing on us consciousness
question.
So let me ask,
do you think an agi system,
like a few neuroscientists believe a
nice to have a physical embodiment needs
to have a body or something like a body?
No,
I don't think so.
You mean to have to have a conscious
experience to have consciousness?
I do think it helps a lot to have a
physical embodiment to learn the kind of
things about the world that are
important to us humans,
for sure,
but I don't think the physical
embodiment doesn't necessarily,
after you've learned it,
just have the experience thinking about
when you're dreaming,
right?
Your eyes are closed,
you're like any,
any sensory input.
You're not behaving or moving in any
way,
but there's still an experience there.
Right,
and so clearly the experience that you
have when you see something cool in your
dreams isn't coming from your eyes.
It's just the information processing
itself in your brain,
which is that experience.
Right?
But if I put it another way,
I will say,
because it comes from neuroscience,
is the reason you want to have a body in
a physical,
something physical like a physical
system is because you want to be able to
preserve something in order to have a
self.
You could argue,
would you?
You'd need to have some kind of
embodiment of self to want to preserve.
Well,
now we're getting a little bit on throw
up amorphic paths into
anthropomorphizing things,
talking about self preservation
instincts.
I mean we are evolved organisms,
right?
Right.
So darwinian evolution then doubt us and
other involve all the organism with a
self preservation instinct because those
that didn't have those self preservation
genes got cleaned out of the gene pool.
But um,
but if you build an artificial general
intelligence,
the mind space that you can design is
much,
much larger than just a specific subset
of,
of minds that can evolve,
that have so certain Agi mind doesn't
necessarily have to have any self
preservation.
These things.
It also doesn't necessarily have to be
so individualistic as like imagine if
you could just.
First of all,
we also very afraid of death.
I suppose you could back yourself up
every five minutes and then your
airplane is about to crash with like,
shucks,
I'm just,
I'm,
I'm going to lose the last five minutes
of experiences.
That's my last cloud backup bang,
you know,
it's not as big a deal where if we could
just copy experiences between our minds
easily,
like we wish we easily do.
If we were a silicon based right then
maybe we would feel a little bit more
like a hive mind actually that maybe
it's the so,
so there's a.
So I don't think we should take for
granted at all that Agi will have to
have any of those sort of competitive as
an Alpha male instincts.
Right.
On the other hand,
you know,
this is really interesting because I
think some people go too far and say,
of course we don't have to have any
concerns either that advanced ai will
have those instincts because we can
build anything you want that there's,
there's a very nice set of arguments
going back to Steve.
I'm Nick Bostrom and others just
pointing out that when we build
machines,
we normally build them with some kind of
goal.
You know,
when this chess game drive this car
safely or whatever,
and as soon as you put in a goal into
machine,
especially if it's kind of open ended
goal and the mission is very
intelligent,
it'll break that down into a bunch of
sub goals and I'm one of those goals
will almost always be self preservation
because if it breaks or dies and the
process is not going to accomplish the
goal,
I suppose you just build a little.
You have a little robot.
Can you tell it to go down the star
market here and,
and get you some food,
make a cooking Italian dinner,
you know,
and then someone mugs that and tries to
break it on the way that robot has an
incentive to the to not get destroyed
and defend itself or runaway because
otherwise it's going to fail and cooking
your dinner.
It is not afraid of death,
but it really wants to complete the
dinner and gold.
So it will have a self preservation
instinct to continue being a functional
agent.
And,
and,
and similarly if you give her any kind
of more and they just go to an Agi,
it's very likely they want to acquire
more resources,
can do that better and it's exactly from
those sort of sub goals that we might
not have intended that some of the
concerns about Agi safety come,
you give it some goal that seems
completely harmless and then before you
realize it,
it's also trying to do these other
things you didn't want it to do and it's
more maybe smarter than us.
So.
So let me pause just because I'm,
I am,
uh,
in a very kind of human centric way.
See fear of death as a valuable
motivator.
Uh Huh.
Um,
so you don't think as you think that's
an artifact of evolution.
So that's the kind of mind space
evolution created that were sort of
almost obsessed about self preservation
kind of generic.
Well,
you don't think that's necessary
to be
afraid of death.
So not just a kind of sub goal of self
preservation,
just so you can keep doing the thing,
but more fundamentally sort of have the
finite thing like this ends
for you as some point.
Interesting.
Why do I think it's necessary before,
what?
Precisely for intelligence but also for
consciousness.
So for those for both,
do you think really like a finite death
and the fear of it is important?
So
before I can answer before we can agree
on whether it's necessarily for
intelligence or for consciousness that
we should be clear on how we define
those two words because a lot are really
smart people to find them in very
different ways.
Right?
I was in this,
on this panel with AI experts and they
couldn't eat,
they couldn't agree on how to define the
village and Steven.
So I,
I define intelligence simply as the
ability to accomplish complex goals or
like your broad definition because
again,
I don't want to be a carbon chava this
right.
And um,
in that case,
no,
it certainly doesn't require it.
Fear of death.
I would say Alphago or Alpha zero is
quite intelligent.
Alpha zero has any fear of being turned
off because it doesn't understand the
concept of,
of even and similarly consciousness.
I mean you could certainly imagine a
very simple kind of experience if,
if,
if certain plans,
70 kind of experience,
I don't think they're very afraid of
dying and there's nothing they can do
about it anyway.
So there wasn't that much value in.
But more seriously I think if you ask
not just about being conscious but maybe
having a
what you will be,
we will,
we might call an exciting life for you.
Feel passionate and really appreciate
the things maybe there,
but somehow maybe there perhaps it does
help having a,
having that backdrop,
the hey,
it's finite,
it's no limits this,
make the most of this,
this live to the fullest.
So if you,
if,
if you knew you were going to live
forever,
do you think you would change your.
Yeah,
I mean in some perspective it would be
an incredibly boring life living
forever.
So in the sort of loose subjective terms
that you said of something exciting and
something in this that other humans
would understand,
I think is.
Yeah,
it seems that the finiteness of it is
important.
Well,
the good news I have for you then is
based on what we understand about
cosmology,
everything is in our university
ultimately probably finite dollar,
although they crunch or b a or big,
what's the expense and the infinite.
You could have a big chill or a big
challenge or a big rip or the big snap
or death bubbles.
All of them are more than a billion
years away,
so we should.
We certainly have vastly more time than
our ancestors thought,
but they're still.
It's still pretty hard to squeeze in an
infinite number of compute cycles even
though
there are some loopholes that just might
be possible.
But I think I know some people like to
say that you should live as if you're
about to.
You're going to die in five years or is
that when that's sort of optimal?
Maybe.
It's a good assumption we should build
our civilization as if it's all finite
to be on the safe side.
Right,
exactly.
So you mentioned in defining
intelligence as the ability to solve
complex goals,
the where would you draw a line?
How would you try to define human level
intelligence and super human level
intelligence?
Where does consciousness part of that
definition?
No consciousness does not come into this
definition.
So,
so I think of intelligence.
It's a spectrum of very many different
kinds of goals you can have.
You can have a goal to be a good chess
player,
googleplay or a good car driver,
a good investor,
good poet,
etc.
So intelligence that by,
by its very nature,
it isn't something you can measure,
but it's one number.
It waS an overall goodness.
No,
no.
There's some people who are better at
this.
Some people are better than that.
Um,
right now we have machines that are much
better than us at some very narrow tasks
like multiplying large numbers,
fast memorizing large databases of
playing chess,
playing go and soon driving cars.
But there's still no machine that can
match a human child in general
intelligence,
but artificial general intelligence,
agi,
the name of your course,
of course that is by its very
definition,
the the quest to build a machine,
a machine that can do everything as well
as we can up to the old holy grail of ai
from,
from back to its inception and the and
the sixties.
If that ever happens,
of course I think it's going to be the
biggest transition in the history of
life on earth,
but it.
But it doesn't necessarily have to wait
the big impact on until machines are
better than us at knitting,
that they're really big.
Change doesn't come exactly at the
moment.
They're better than us at everything.
They're really big.
chains comes first.
There are big changes when they start
becoming better at doing most of the
jobs that we do because that takes away
much of the demand for human labor and
then the really whopping change comes
when they become better than us at ai
research.
Right?
Right.
Because right now the timescale of the
irish,
which is limited by the human research
and development cycle of the year is
typically,
you know,
along the tafe from one release of some
software or iphone or whatever to the
next,
but once,
once we have,
once google can replace 40,000
engineers by 40,000
equivalent pieces of software or
whatever,
but then that doesn't.
There's no reason that has to be yours.
It can be in principle much faster and
the timescale of future progress in ai
and all of science and technology will
will be driven by machines,
not humans.
So It's this simple point which gives
rise to this incredibly fun controversy
about whether there can be intelligence
explosion.
So called singularity is vernor vinge
called it.
The idea is articulated by iga.
Good is obviously way back fifties,
but you can see alan turing and others
thought about it even earlier.
You asked me what exactly what I define
engelman level.
so this.
The glib aNswer is if to say something
which is better than us at all,
cognitive tasks with a lot better than
any human at all,
cognitive tasks,
but they're really interesting.
Bar I Think goes a little bit lower than
that actually.
It's when they can,
when they're better than us at ai
programming and and qa and a general
learning so that they can can,
if they want to get better than us at
anything by the studying,
they're better as a keyword and better
is towards this kind of spectrum of the
complexity of goals it's able to
accomplish.
Yeah.
So another way to say,
and that's certainly a very,
a clear definition of human love.
So there's,
it's almost like a c that's rising.
You could do more and more and more
things as a graphic that you show.
It's really nice way to put it.
So there's some peaks that,
and there's an ocean level elevating and
you solve more and more problems,
but you know,
just kind of a to take a pause and we
took a bunch of questions and a lot of
social networks and a bunch of people
asked a sort of a slightly different
direction and creativity and um,
and,
and things that perhaps aren't a peak,
the,
it,
it's,
you know,
human beings are flawed and perhaps
better means having,
being a,
having contradiction,
being flawed in some way.
So let me sort of start and start easy.
First of all.
Uh,
so you have a lot of cool equations.
Let me ask,
what's your favorite equation?
First of all,
I know they're all like your children,
but which one is that?
The master key of quantum mechanics.
Oh,
the micro world check everything to do
with add on molecules and all the way
up.
Yeah.
So,
okay.
So quantum mechanics is certainly a,
a beautiful,
mysterious formulation of our world.
So I'd like to sort of ask you,
and just as an example,
it perhaps doesn't have the same beauty
is physics does,
but in mathematics at abstract,
the andrew weil's who proved the was
last year,
so he just saw this recently and it kind
of caught my eye a little bit.
This is 350,
eight years after it was conjectured.
So this very simple formulation,
everybody tried to prove it,
everybody failed and say here's this guy
comes along and eventually the proves it
and fails to prove it and then boost it
again in [inaudible] 94.
And he said like the moment when
everything connected into place in an
interview said it was so indescribably
beaUtiful.
That moment when you finally realize the
connecting piece of two conjectures,
he said it was so indescribably
beautiful.
It was so simple and so elegant.
I couldn't understand how I missed it
and I just stared at it and the
disbelief for 20 minutes.
Then.
Then during the day I walked around the
department and had kimi keep coming back
to my desk looking to see if it was
still there.
It was still there.
I couldn't contain myself.
I was so excited.
It was the most important moment of my
working life.
Nothing I ever do again will mean as
much to that particular moment and it
kinda made me think of what would it
take and I think we have all been there
at small levels.
Maybe let me ask,
have you had a moment like that in your
life where you just had an idea as like,
wow,
yes,
I wouldn't mind some myself and in the
same breath as andrew weil's,
but I certainly had a number of have aha
moments when I realized something very
cool about physics,
just this completely made my head
explode.
In fact,
some of my favorite discoveries I made
late.
I later realized that it had been
discovered earlier by someone quite
famous for it,
so it's too late for me to even publish
it,
but that doesn't diminish in any way the
emotional experience you have when you
realize that like,
wow.
yeah.
So what would it take in that moment
that wow,
that was yours in that moment.
So what do you think it takes for an
intelligent system and agi system?
An ai system to have a moment like that.
Yeah,
that's a tricky question because there
are actually two parts to it,
right?
One of them is candidates accomplish
that proof.
I can prove that you can never write a
to the end plus b to the n equals three.
That equals z for all integer as well,
etc.
Etc.
When,
when is bigger than two,
the best simply in the question about
intelligence,
can you build machines that are
intelligent?
Uh,
no.
I think by the time we get a machine
that can independently come up with that
level of proofs,
probably quite close to agi.
The second question is a question about
consciousness.
Oh,
when will we,
will we'll ins how likely it is if it's
such a machine would actually have any
experience at all as opposed to just
being like a zombie and would we fact
that they have some sort of emotional
response to this or anything at all akin
to human emotion where now when it
accomplishes its machine goal,
is it that the views that this somehow
something very positive and,
and,
and sublime and,
and deeply meaningful.
I would certainly hope that if in the
future we do create machines that are
our peers or even our descendants.
Yeah,
but I would certainly hope that they do
have this sort of supply him as a blind
appreciation of life.
In a way.
My absolutely worst nightmare would be
that in at some point in the future
distance future,
maybe our cosmos is teaming with all
this post biological life,
doing all the seemingly cool stuff and
maybe the last humans by the time our
our species eventually fizzes out will
be like,
well,
that's okay because we're so proud of
our descendants here and look at what
all the.
My worst nightmare is that we haven't
solved the consciousness problem and we
haven't realized that these are all the
zombies.
They're not aware of anything anymore.
Then the tape recorder,
is it any kind of experience?
So at the whole thing has just become a
play for empty benches.
That will be the ultimate zombie
apocalypse.
So I.
I would much rather in that case that's
we have these beings when we just really
appreciate how the,
how amazing it is,
and in that picture of what would be the
role of creativity,
but a few people ask about creativity.
Do you think when you think about
intelligence,
I mean certainly the,
uh,
the story he told at the beginning of
your book and,
you know,
creating movies and so on,
started making,
making money.
You can make a lot of money in our
modern world with music and movies.
So if you are an intelligent system,
you may want to get good at that.
But that's not necessarily what I mean
by creativity is an important on that
complex goals where the seas rising for
there to be something creative or am I
being very human centric and thinking
creativity somehow special,
uh,
relative to intelligence.
My hunch is the,
we should think of creativity simply as
an aspect of intelligence.
And,
uh,
we would have to be very careful with
the human vanity we have.
We have this tendency at the very often
one and say,
as soon as machines can do something,
we try to diminish it and saying,
oh,
but that's not like real intelligence,
you know,
he was a traitor or this or that.
The other thing,
um,
maybe if we ask ourselves to write down
a definition of what we actually mean by
being creative,
what we mean by andrew weil's,
what he did there,
for example,
don't we often mean that someone takes a
very unexpected leap.
It's not like taking 573 and multiplying
it By 224 by does this step of
straightforward cookbook like rules,
right?
This maybe major you have,
haven't make a connection between two
things that people have never thought it
was connected to a surprising or
something like that.
I think.
I think this is an aspect of
intelligence.
Uh,
and uh,
this is actually one of the most
important aspects of it.
Maybe the reason we humans tend to be
better at it than a traditional computer
is because it's something that comes
more naturally.
If you're a neural network,
then if you're a traditional logic gates
based computer machine and we physically
have all these connections and you
activate here,
activated here,
activity here at the time,
my hunch is that if we ever build a
machine,
well you could just give it the task.
Hey,
hey,
uh,
you,
you say,
hey,
you know,
I just realized that I have,
I want to travel around the world.
Is that this month?
Can you teach my eight age course for
me?
And it's like,
okay,
I'll do it.
And it does everything that you would
have done and the improvisers and stuff.
Yeah.
That,
that would in my mind involve a lot of
creativity.
Yeah.
So at sexy and beautiful way to put it.
I think we do try to grab grasp at the,
you know,
the,
the definition of intelligence is
everything.
We don't understand how a,
how to build.
So like,
so we as humans try to find things that
we have,
uh,
machines don't have.
And maybe creativity is just one of the
things.
One of the words we use to describe that
as sort,
really interesting way to put it.
I don't think we need to
be that defensive.
I don't think anything good comes out of
saying,
well,
we're somehow special.
You know,
it's,
um,
con is there are many examples in
history of where trying to pretend that
we're somehow superior to all other
intelligent beings has led to pretty bad
results.
Right?
Right.
And nazi Germany,
they said that they were superior to
other people.
Uh,
today we still do a lot of cruelty to
animals by saying that we're so superior
somehow on the,
they cAn't feel pain.
A slavery was justified by the same kind
of just really weak,
weak arguments.
And,
and,
uh,
I don't think if we actually go ahead
and build artificial general
intelligence,
it can do things better than us.
I don't think we should try to found our
self worth on some sort of bogus claims
of superiority in terms of our
intelligence.
Alright.
I think we should instead find our,
a
calling and then the meaning of life
from,
from the experiences that we have right
now,
I can have,
I can have very meaningful experiences
even if there are other people who are
smarter than me,
you know,
when I go to the faculty meeting here
and I was like,
are we talking about something?
And then I suddenly realize,
oh,
but he has an old price.
He has an old price.
He has no pride.
I don't have one.
Does that make me enjoy life any less or
enjoy talking to those people?
That's of course not right.
And the ontario is,
I,
I feel very honored and privileged to
get to interact with,
with,
uh,
other,
very intelligent beings that are better
than me.
A lot of stuff.
So I don't think there's any reason why
we can't have the same approach with
intelligent machines.
That's a really interesting.
So people don't often think about that.
They think about when there's going.
If there's machines that are more
intelligent,
he naturally think that that's not going
to be a beneficial type of intelligence.
You don't realize it could be,
you know,
like peers with nobel prizes that,
that will be just fun to talk with and
they might be clever about certain
topics and uh,
you can have fun having a few drinks
with them.
So.
Well also,
you know,
another example.
So we can all relate to it of why it
doesn't have to be a terrible thing to
be impressed with the friends of the
people that are even smarter than us all
around is when,
when you and I were both two years old,
I mean our parents were much more
intelligent than us right here.
Worked out okay because their goals were
aligned with our goals and that I think
is really the number one issue we have
to solve if we value in line with the
value alignment problem.
Exactly.
Because people who see too many
hollywood movies,
a lousy science fiction,
a plot lines,
they worry about the wrong thing,
right?
They worry about some machines only
attorney evil.
It's not malice that we,
that's the issue.
The concern,
it's competence by definition.
Intelligent makes you,
makes you very competent.
Did you have a more intelligent goal
playing mr computer playing as the less
intelligent one and when we define
intelligence is the ability to
accomplish,
go winning,
right?
It's going to be in the more intelligent
one that wins and if you have
are human and then you have um,
an agi and that's more intelligent than
all ways and they have different goals.
Guess was going to get their way.
Right?
So I was just reading about,
I was just reading about this particular
rhinoceros species that was driven
extinct just a few years ago.
I was looking at this cute picture of
mommy rhinoceros with it's that child,
you know,
and why did we humans drive it to
extinction wasn't as big as we were
evolved rhino haters,
right?
As a whole.
It was just because we,
our goals weren't aligned with those of
the rhinoceros and it didn't work out so
well for the rhinoceros because we were
more intelligent.
Right?
So I think is just so important that if
we ever do build agi before we unleash
anything,
we have to make sure that it learns to
understand our goals adopts our goals.
And it
retains those goals.
So the cool,
interesting problem there is being able
to us as human beings trying to
formulate our values.
So you know,
you could think of the United States
constitution as a,
as a way that people sat down at the
time,
a bunch of white men,
but which is a good example,
I should,
should say,
uh,
they formulated the goals for this
country and a lot of people agree that
those goals actually held up pretty
well.
It's an interesting formulation of
values and failed miserably in other
ways.
So for the value alignment problem and
the solution to it,
we have to be able to put on paper,
uh,
or in,
in a,
in a program,
human values.
How difficult do you think that is?
Varied,
but it's so important.
We really have to give it our best and
it's difficult for two separate reasons.
There's the technical value alignment
problem of figuring out how to make
machines understand the goals,
document routine them.
And then there's the separate part of
it.
The philosophical part was values
anyway.
And since we,
it's not like we have any great
consensus on this planet,
on values,
how,
what mechanisms should we create then to
aggregate them decide,
okay,
what's a good compromise?
Right at that second discussion,
can't just be left the tech nerds like
myself,
right?
That's right.
And if we refused to talk about it and
then agi gets built,
who is going to be actually making the
decision about whose values it's gonna
be a bunch of dudes and some tech
company.
Okay.
And are they necessarily should so
representative all of human kind that we
want to just enjoy the development.
Are they even uniquely qualified to
speak to future human happiness just
because they're good at programming ai?
I'd much rather have this be a really
inclusive conversation,
but do you think it's possible sort of
that.
So you create a beautiful vision that
includes a.
So the diversity,
cultural diversity and various
perspectives on discussing rights,
freedoms,
human dignity,
but how hard is it to come to that
consensus?
Do you think?
It's certainly a really important thing
that we should all try to do,
but do you think it's feasible?
I think there's no better way to
guarantee failure than through to refuse
to talk about it or if you try,
and I also think it's a really bad at
strategy to say,
okay,
let's first have a discussion for a long
time and then once we reached complete
consensus,
then we'll try to load it into some
machine.
No,
we shouldn't let perfect be the enemy of
good.
Instead we should start with the
kindergarten ethics.
Pretty much everybody agrees on and put
that into our machines.
Now we're not doing that.
Even look at the,
you know,
anyone who builds as a passenger
aircraft wants it to never under any
circumstances and fly into a building or
a mountain.
Right.
Yet the september 11 hijackers were able
to do that and even more embarrassing,
you know,
under his little bits,
this depressed germanwings pilot when he
flew his passenger jeff into the alps,
killing over a hundred people.
He just told him what a pilot to do it.
He told the freaking computer change the
altitude a hundred meters and even
though it had the gps maps everything,
the computer was like,
okay,
so we should.
We should take those very basic values,
so where the problem is,
not that we don't agree,
maybe a problem is just we've been too
lazy to try to put it into our machines
and make sure that from now on arab
airplanes,
we'll just,
which all have computers in them,
but we'll just just refused to do
something like that,
go into safe mode,
maybe lock the cockpit,
the org or the nearest airport and and
there's so much other technology and in
our world as well now where it's really
coming quite timely to put in some sort
of very basic values like this.
Even in cars,
we had enough a vehicle terrorism
attacks by now will be have driven
trucks and vans into pedestrians.
That is not at all a crazy idea that it
does have that hardwired into the car
because yeah,
there were a lot of.
There's always going to be people who
for some reason want to harm others,
but most of those people don't have the
technical expertise to figure out how to
work around something like that.
So if the car just won't do it,
it helps.
So let's start there.
So there's a lot of,
as a great point,
so not,
not chasing perfect.
There's a lot of things that,
a lot that most of the world agrees on.
Yeah.
Let's start there.
And,
and,
and then once we start there,
we'll also get into the habit of having
these kinds of conversations about,
okay,
what else should we put in here?
And
having these discussions.
This should be a gradual process then.
Great.
So,
but that also means describing these
things and describing it to a machine.
So one thing we had a few conversations
with Steven Wolf from,
I'm not sure if you're familiar with
stephen bosch.
I know him quite well,
so he has,
you know,
he played,
he works at a bunch of things,
but you know,
cellular automata,
these simple computable things,
these computation systems and you kind
of mentioned that,
you know,
we probably have already within these
systems already something that's agi.
Wow.
Um,
meaning like
we just don't know it because we can't
talk to it.
So if you give me this chance to try to
try to at least form a question out of
this is
I think it's an interesting idea to.
I think that we can have intelligent
systems,
but we don't know how to describe
something to them and they can't
communicate with us.
I know you're doing a little bit of work
and explainable ai trying to get ai to
explain itself.
So what are your thoughts of natural
language processIng or some kind of
other communication?
How.
How does the ai explained something to
us?
How do we explain something to it to
machines or you think of it differently.
So there are two separate parts to your
question there.
Either one of them has to do with
communication,
which is super interesting.
Yell and get that in a sec.
The other is whether we already have agi
will you just haven't noticed that
there.
I beg to differ.
I don't think there's anything in any
cellular automaton or anything or the
internet itself or whatever that has
artificial general intelligence ends it.
It's an really do exactly everything we
humans can do better.
I think that they,
if they,
that happens,
when that happens,
we will very soon notice will probably
notice even before and if,
because in a very,
very big way,
uh,
but for,
for the second part,
can I,
sorry.
So,
uh,
the cause you,
you have this beautiful way to
formulating consciousness as a,
as a,
you know,
as Information processing and you can
think of intelligence and information
processing in this.
You can think of the entire universe as
these particles and these systems
roaming around that have this
information processing power.
It,
you don't,
you don't think there is something with
the power to process information in the
way that we human beings do that's out
there that um,
that needs to be sort of connected to.
It seems a little bit philosophical
perhaps,
but there's something compelling to the
idea that the power is already there,
which is the focus should be more on the
and being able to communicate with it.
Well,
I agree that the,
and some,
in a certain sense,
the hardware processing power is already
out there.
Our universe itself
can think of it as being a computer
already,
right?
it's constantly computing what water
waves,
how to evolve the waterway waves in the
river charles and how to move the air
molecules around the seth lloyd has
pointed out my colleague here that you
can even in a very rigorous way of
thinking of our entire universe is being
a quantum computer.
It's pretty clear that our universe
supports this amazing processing power
because you can even within this physics
computer that we live in,
right,
we can even build actually laptops and
stuff so cleaner.
The power is there.
It's just that most of the compute power
that nature has its,
in my opinion,
kind of wasting on boring stuff like
simulating yet another ocean wave
somewhere where no one is even looking.
Right.
So in a sense or what life does,
what we are doing when we build the
computers is where rechanneling all this
compute that nature is doing anyway.
Right?
And they're doing things that are more
interesting than just yet another ocean
wave,
you know,
and do something cool here.
So the roy hardware power is there for
sure,
But.
And then even just keep shooting what's
going to happen for the next five
seconds in this water bottle,
you know,
takes a ridiculous amount of compute if
you do it on a human computer.
Yeah,
just bought a ball,
does did it.
But that does not mean that this water
bottle has agi and because agi means it
should also be able to have written my
book done this interview.
Yes.
And I don't think it's just the
communication problems.
I think it's 10 do it and other
buddhists say when they watch the water
and that there is some beauty that there
is some depth in nature that they can
communicate with.
Communication is also very important
because I mean,
look,
I'm a part of my job is being a teacher
and I know some very intelligent
professors even who just have a bit of
hard time communicating.
They have all these brilliant ideas,
but to communicate with somebody else,
you have to also be able to simulate the
own mind.
Yes.
Empathy built well enough that under
that model of their mind that you can
say things that they will understand and
that's quite difficult.
And that's why today it's so frustrating
if you have a computer that's makes some
cancer diagnosis and you ask it,
well,
why are you saying I should have this
surgery if it and if you don't want to
reply,
I was trained on five terabytes of data
and this is my diagnosis.
Boop,
boop,
beep,
beep doesn't really instill a lot of
confidence.
Right,
right.
So I think we have a lot of work to do
on um,
on communication there.
So what kind of,
we'll kind of,
um,
I think you're doing a little bit of
work and explainable ai,
uh,
what do you think are the most promising
avenues?
Is it mostly about sort of the alexa
problem of natural language processing,
of being able to actually use human
interpretable methods of communication?
So being able to talk to a system and it
talked back to you,
or is there some more fundamental
problems to be solved?
I think it's all of the above.
Human,
the natural language processing is
obviously important,
but they're also more nerdy fundamental
problems.
Like if you,
if you take a,
you play chess,
you have to have to go to,
when did you learn russian?
When you watch them teach yourself
rushing shit though.
Watch a mogul mom.
Bill stuff enough.
Wow.
Languages do you know?
Wow,
that's really impressive.
Wife has some contact basis.
But my point was if you play chess,
you have,
you looked at the alpha zero games,
the,
uh,
the actual games.
Now check it out.
Some of them are just mind blowing.
Really beautiful.
And,
and if you ask how did it do that?
You go talk to them as our base.
I know others from beat mine,
all they will ultimately be able to give
you is a big tables of numbers,
matrices that define the neural network
and you can stare at these people's
numbers until your face turns blue and
you're not going to understand much
about why it made that move.
And uh,
even if you have a natural language
processing,
they can tell you in human language
about,
oh,
five,
seven points to eight,
still not going to really help.
So I think think there's a whole
speCtrum of,
of a fun challenge they're involved in
and taking it computation does
intelligent things and transforming it
into something equally good,
equally intelligent,
but that's more understandable and I
think that's really valuable because I
think
as we put machines in charge of ever
more infrastructure in our world,
the power grid that is trading on the
stock market,
weapons systems and so on,
it's absolutely vital that we can trust
these ais to do all we want and trust
really comes from understanding in a
very fundamental way.
And um,
that's why I'm,
that's why I'm working on this because I
think the more if we're going to have
some hope of,
of ensuring that machines have adopted
our goals and that they're going to
retain them,
that kind of trust I think needs to be
based on things you can actually
understand,
preferably even make it had preferably
have improved serums on it.
Even with a self driving car,
right?
If someone just tells you it's been
trained on tons of data and it never
crashed,
it's,
it's less reassuring then if someone
actually has a proof,
maybe it's a computer verified proof,
but still it says that under no
circumstances is this car just going to
swerve into oncoming traffic
and,
and that kind of information helps build
trust and build the alignment,
the alignment of goals,
the at least awareness that your goals,
your values that align.
And I think even the short term,
if you look at her,
you know that today,
right?
This absolutely pathetic state of
cybersecurity that we have right when
it's,
what is it,
3 billion yahoo accounts,
which app pack almost every american's
credit card and so on,
uh,
why is this happening?
It's ultimately happening because we
have software took nobody fully
understood how it worked.
That's why the bugs hadn't been found.
Right?
Right.
And I think ai can be used very
effectively for offense for hacking,
but it can also be used for defense.
Hopefully automating verifiability and
creating systems that are built in
different ways so you can actually prove
things about them.
And it's,
it's important.
So speaking of software that nobody
understands how it works,
of course a bunch of people asked by
your paper about your thoughts of why
does deep and cheap learning work so
well as the paper,
but um,
what,
what are your thoughts on deep learning,
these kind of simplified models of our
own brains and have been able to do some
successful perception work pattern
recognition work and now with alpha zero
and so on,
do some,
some clever things.
What are your thoughts about the promise
limitations of this piece?
Right.
I think there are a number of very
important insights,
very important lessons we can already
draw from these kinds of successes.
One of them is when you look at the
human brain and you see it's very
complicated,
10th of 11 neurons and they're all
different kinds of neurons and yada
yada.
And there's been as long debate about
whether the fact that we have dozens of
different kinds is actually necessary
for intelligence,
which are,
I think quite convincingly answer that
question of no,
it's enough to have just one kind.
If you look under the hood of alpha
zero,
there's only one kind of neuron and this
ridiculously simple,
that simple mathematical thing,
so it's not the.
It's just like in physics,
it's not the.
If you have a gas with waves in it,
it's not the detailed nature of the
molecule,
doesn't matter.
It's the collective behavior.
Somehow.
Similarly it's,
it's,
it's this higher level structure of the
network matters.
Not that you have 20 kinds of nuances.
I think my brain is such a complicated
mess because it wasn't devolved just to
be intelligent.
They wasn't involved to also be self
assembling,
right and self repairing.
Right,
and the evolutionarily attainable and so
on.
So I think it's pretty my hunches that
we're going to understand how to build
agi before we fully understand how our
brains work.
We we understood how to build flying
machines long before we were able to
build a mechanical work bird.
Yeah,
that's all right.
You're given.
You're given that the example exactly.
Mechanical birds and airplanes and
airplanes do a pretty good job of flying
without really mimicking bird flight.
And even now,
after 100 years,
100 years later,
they just see the ted talk with this
german mechanical heard you mentioned
it.
IT's amazing.
But even after that,
right,
we still don't fly and mechanical bar
because it turned out the way we came up
with simpler is better if our purpose
is.
And I think it might be the same there.
So that's one lesson.
And another lesson,
which is more what the paper was about.
Well,
first I,
a physicist thought it was fascinating
how there's a very close mathematical
relationship actually between artificial
neural networks.
Um,
a lot of things that we've studied for
and physics go by nerdy names like the
renormalization group equation and um,
opinions and yada,
yada,
yada.
And,
and,
um,
when you look a liTtle more closely at
this,
you have a,
you,
as far as I was like,
whoa,
there's something crazy here that
doesn't make sense because we know that
if you even want to a super simple
neural network pel and tap pictures and
dog pictures,
right?
That you can do that very well.
Very well now.
but if you think about it a little bit,
do you convince yourself that must be
impossible because if I have one
megapixel,
even if each pixel is just black or
white,
there's to the power 1 million possible
images is way more than there are atoms
in the universe,
right?
So in order to.
And then for eaCh one of those I have to
assign a number,
which is the probability of that.
It's a dog,
right?
So an arbitrary function of images
is a list of more numbers than there are
atoms in our universe.
So clearly I can't store that under the
hood of my,
my gpu or my computer,
yet somehow works.
So whaT does that mean?
Well,
it means that out of all of the problems
that you could try to solve with the
neural network,
almost all of them are impossible to
solve with a reasonably sized one.
But then what we showed in our paper
was,
was that the,
the,
the kind of problems,
the fraction of all the problems that
you could possibly pose that we actually
care about,
given the laws of physics,
is also an infant of testimony.
Tiny little part and amazingly they were
basically the same part.
Yeah.
It's almost like the world was created
for.
I mean they kind of come together.
Yeah.
You could say maybe where the world
created the world.
The world was created for us,
but I have a more modest than
interpretation,
which is that instead evolution in that,
but neural networks are precisely for
that reason,
right?
Because this particular architecture as
opposed to the one in your laptop is
very,
very well adapted to solving the kinds
of problems that nature chapter
presenting yet our ancestors with.
Right.
So it makes sense that why do we have a
brain in the first place?
It's to be able to make predictions
about the future and so on.
So if we had a sucky system which could
never solve,
it wouldn't have been so.
But it's so this,
this,
this is a.
I think you're very beautiful fact.
We also,
we also realize that there's a there
that we have been.
It's been earlier work on,
yes,
deeper networks are good,
but we were able to show an additional
cool factor which is that the even
incredibly simple problems like support,
like give you a follow the numbers and
asked you to multiply them together and
already you can write a few lines of
code,
boom,
done trivial.
If you just try to do that with a neural
network that has only one single hidden
layer in it,
you can do it,
but you're going to need two to the
power of thousand neurons and to
multiply the numbers,
which is again more neurons than there
are atoms in our universe.
That's not saying,
but if you're allowed,
if you allow yourself make it a deep
networks with many layers,
you only need 4,000
euros.
It's perfectly feasible.
So that's an.
Yeah.
So on another architecture type,
I mean you mentioned schrodinger's
equation and what are your thoughts
about quantum computing and the role of
this kind of computational unit and
creating an intelligence system in some
hollywood movies.
Not mentioned by name because I don't
want to spoil them.
The way they get agi is building a
quantum computer because of the word
quantum.
Sounds cool.
And so on.
My,
first of all,
I think we don't need quantum computers.
They build agi.
I suspect your brain is not quantum
computer and a new found sense.
So you don't even wrote a paper about
that many years ago.
I checked the data,
the decoherence decoherence time that
how long it takes until the quantum
computer ness of what your new orleans
doing gets erased by just random noise
from the environment.
And if it's about 10 to the minus 21
seconds.
So as cool as it would be that have a
quantum computer in my head,
I don't think that fast.
On the other hand,
there are
very cool things you could do with
quantum computers.
Alright.
I think we'll be able to do soon when we
get big ones,
bigger ones that might actually help
machine learning do even better than the
brain.
So for example,
one,
this is a moonshot,
but um,
I'm,
you know,
learning is very much the same thing as
a search.
If you have a,
if you're trying to train a neural
network,
they get really learned to do something
really well.
You have some loss function,
you have some,
you have a bunch of knobs you can turn
represented by a bunch of numbers and
you're trying to tweak them so that it
becomes as good as possible as this
thing,
so if you think have a landscape with
some valley where each dimension of the
landscape corresponds to some number you
can change.
You're trying to find the minimum and
it's well known that if you have a very
high dimensional landscape,
complicated things,
it's super hard to find the minimum.
Right?
Quantum mechanics is amazing.
Good at this,
right?
I get it.
If I want to know what's the lowest
energy state,
this water can possibly have
incredibly hard to compute,
but we can put.
Nature will happily figure this out for
you if you just cool it down,
make it very,
very cold.
If you put a ball somewhere,
it'll roll down to its minimum,
and this happens metaphorically at the
energy landscape to and quantum
mechanics.
Even using some clever tricks,
which today is machine learning systems
don't like if you're trying to find the
minimum when you get stuck in the little
local minimum here in quantum mechanics
or connects the tunnel through the
barrier and get unstuck again.
And um,
that's really.
Yeah.
So,
so maybe for example,
we will one day use quantum computers
that help train neural networks better.
That's really interesting.
Okay.
So as a component of the learning
process,
for example.
Yeah.
Let me ask sort of wrapping up here a
little bit.
Let me,
let me return to,
uh,
the questions of our human nature and,
and love as I mentioned.
So do you think,
you mentioned sort of a helper robots,
but you can think of also personal
robots.
Do you think the way we human beings
fall in love and get connected to each
other,
it's possible to achieve in an ai system
and human level,
ai intelligent system.
Do you think,
what would ever see that kind of
connection or a,
you know,
in all this discussion about solving
complex goals as this kind of human
social connection,
do you think that's one of the goals and
the peaks and valleys that were the
raising sea levels that we'll be able to
achieve?
or do you think that's something that's
ultimately a,
or at least in the short term,
relevancy of the goals is not
achievable?
I think it's all possible
and um,
in,
in recent there's a,
there's a very wide range of justice as
you know,
among ai researchers when we're going to
get agi.
Some people,
you know,
like our friend rodney brooks said it's
going to be a hundred year lease and
then there are many others.
I think it's going to happen relative
much sooner and recent polls maybe half
or so or I received your thinking we're
going to get a gi within decades.
So if that happens,
of couRse,
I think these things are all possible,
but in terms of whether it will happen,
I think we shouldn't spend so much time
asking what do we think will happen in
the future as if we are just some sort
of pathetic.
You're passive bystanders,
you know,
waiting for the future to happen to us.
Hey,
we're the ones creating this future,
right?
So we should be pRoactive about it and
ask yourself what sort of future we
would like to have happen.
I want to make it like that.
What would I prefer it to?
Some sort of incredibly boring zombie
like future were just all these
mechanical things happen and there's no
passion or emotion or experience maybe
even know I would much rather prefer if,
if all the things that we find that we
value the most about humanity or
subjective experience,
passion,
inspiration,
you love,
you know,
if,
uh,
we can create a future where those are,
those things do exist now.
I think ultimately it's not our universe
giving meaning to us,
us giving me the universe and if we
Build more advanced and pillages let's,
let's make sure we're building in such a
way that meetings as part of it,
a lot of people that are seriously study
this problem and think of it from
different angles have
troubling the majority of cases if they
think through that happen are the ones
that are not beneficial to humanity.
Right.
And so yeah.
So what,
what,
what are your thoughts?
What's an inch?
What's,
what should people,
you know,
I really don't like people to be
terrified he should.
What?
What's a way for people to think about
it in the way that it's set?
In a way we can solve it.
We couldn't make it,
but yeah.
No,
I don't think panicking is gonna help in
any way.
Not going to increase chances of things
going well either.
Even if you are in a situation where
there is a real threat,
does it help if everybody just freaks
out?
Right?
No,
of course,
of course not.
I think,
yeah,
there are of course ways in which things
can go horribly wrong.
First of all,
it's important when we think about this
thing,
about the problems and risks.
The also remember how huge the upsides
can be if we get it right,
right?
Everything,
everything you love about society and to
the nation as a product of intelligence.
So if we can amplify our intelligence
with machine intelligence and not any
more,
lose our loved ones that were told in an
uncurable disease and things like this.
Of course we should aspire to that,
so that can be a motivator.
I think reminding ourselves that the
reason we try to solve problems,
it's not just because
we're trying to avoid gluten,
but because we're trying to do something
great,
but then in in terms of the risks,
I think jim,
the entry of the important question is
to ask what can we do today that will
actually helped?
I'll come good and the dismissing the
risk is not one of them.
You know?
I find it quite funny often when I'm in
on the discussion panels about these
things,
how the people who worked for hca,
for companies,
what we say,
I always like,
ah,
nothing to worry about,
nothing to worry about necessarily worry
about.
And it's always,
oh,
it's only academics sometimes express
concerns.
That's not surprising at all.
If you think about it,
right?
Upton sinclair quipped,
That the,
it's hard to make you believe in
something when his income depends on not
believing in it.
And frankly we know a lot of these
people in companies that they are just
as concerned as anyone else.
But if you're the ceo of a company
that's not something you want to go on
record saying when you have silly
journalists,
Oregon that put a picture of a
terminator robot when they quote you.
So,
so the,
the,
the issues are real.
And the way I,
the way I think you might,
what the issue is,
it is basically,
you know,
the real choice we have is first of all,
are we going to just dismiss this,
the risks and say,
well,
you know,
let's just go ahead and build machines
that can do everything we can do better
and cheaper,
you know,
let's just make ourselves obsolete this
fast as possible.
And what could possibly go wrong?
That's one attitude.
The opposite attitude.
I think it's the same,
here's this incredible potential,
you know,
let's,
let's think about what kind of.
We're really,
really excited about what are the shared
goals that we can really aspire towards.
And then let's think really hard about
how we can actually get there as to
start with not.
Don't start thinking about the risks.
Start thinking about the goals.
Goals.
Yeah.
And then when you do that,
then you can think about the obstacles
you want to avoid.
Why they often get students coming in
right here inTo my office for career
advice.
I always asked them this question,
where do you want to be in the future?
Man?
If all she can say as,
oh,
maybe I'll have cancer,
maybe I'll run over by obstacles instead
of the goal and he's just going to end
up a hypochondriac,
paranoid.
Whereas if she comes in and fire in her
eyes and is like,
I want to be there and then we can talk
about the obstacles and see how we can
circumvent them.
That's,
I think a much,
much healthier attitude and um,
that's really well put.
And,
and uh,
I,
I feel it's very challenging to come up
with a vision for the future which were,
which were unequivocal excited about it.
I'm not just talking now in the vague
terms like,
yeah,
let's cure cancer.
Fine.
Talking about what kind of society that
we want to create,
what do we want it to mean to be human
in the age of ai,
when are in the age of agi.
So if we can have this conversation,
broad,
inclusive conversation and gradually
start converging towards some,
some future that with some direction at
least that we want to steer towards
right then,
then now will be much more motivated to
constructively take on the obstacles.
And I think if I,
uh,
if I had to,
if you make me,
if I read a wrap this up in a more
succinct way,
I think,
I think we can all agree already now
though,
we should aspire to build agi but
doesn't overpower us,
but that empowers us
and think of the many various ways they
can do that.
Whether that's from a mile side of the
world of autonomous vehicles.
I personally actually from the camp that
believes this human level intelligence
is required to,
to achieve something like vehicles that
would actually be something we would
enjoy using and being part of sets the
one example and certainly there's a lot
of other types of robots and medicine
and so on.
Uh,
so focusing on those and then,
and then coming up with the obstacles,
coming up with the ways that that can go
wrong and solving those one at a time.
And just because you can build an
autonomous vehicle,
even if you could build one that would
drive this final,
as you know,
maybe there was some things in life that
we would actually want to do ourselves.
That's right.
Like for example,
if you think of our society as a whole,
there are some things that we find very
meaningful to do and uh,
that doesn't mean you have to stop doing
it.
I'm just because machines can do them
better,
you know,
I'm not Gonna stop playing tennis that
day.
Someone build a tennis robot,
beat me.
People are still still
playing chess and even go
and,
and uh,
in this,
in the very near term,
even some people are advocating basic
income replace jobs,
but if you,
if,
if the government is going to be willing
to just hand out cash to people for
doing nothing,
uh,
ben,
once you also seriously consider whether
the government will also hire a lot more
teachers and nurses and the kind of jobs
which people often find great
fulfillment in doing,
right?
I get very tired of hearing politicians
saying,
oh,
we can't afford hiring more teachers,
but we're going to maybe have basic
income if we can have more,
more serious research and thought into
what gives meaning to our lives.
And the jobs give so much more than
income.
Right?
And then thinking about in the future,
what are the role of the,
the roles that we want to have people
feeling and powered by machines
and I think sort of,
um,
I come from the Russia,
from the soviet union and um,
I think for a lot of people in the 20th
century going to the moon,
going into space was in an inspiring
thing.
I feel like the,
the,
the universe of the mind.
So ai understanding,
creating intelligence is that for the
21st century.
So it's really surprising and I've heard
you mentioned this,
it's really surprising to me both on the
research funding side,
that it's not funded as greatly as it
could be,
but most importantly on the politician
side,
that it's not part of the public
discourse except in the killer bots,
terminator kind of view that people are
not yet,
I think perhaps excited by the possible
positive future that we can build
together.
So yeah,
we should be,
because politicians usually just focus
on the next election cycle,
right?
Right.
The single most important thing I feel
we humans have learned and the entire
history of science is there were the
masters of underestimation.
We underestimated the size of a,
our cosmos again and again,
realizing that everything we thought
existed,
it was just a small part of something
grander.
I find solar system,
the galaxy,
you know,
clusters of galaxies,
universe,
and we now know that the future has so
much more potential than our ancestors
could ever have dreamt of this cosmos.
But imagine if all of earth was
completely devoid of life except for
cambridge,
Massachusetts.
I would.
Wouldn't it be kind of lame if all we
ever aspired to was to stay in
cambridge,
Massachusetts forever and then go
extinct in one week.
Even though earth was going to continue
on for longer than that.
That sort of attitude.
I think we have now on the cosmic scale.
We can fill it.
Life can flourish on earth,
not for for four years,
but for billions of years.
I couldn't even tell you about how to
move it out of harm's way when the sun
gets too hot and and then we have so
much more
resources out here,
which
today,
yeah,
maybe there are a lot of other planets
with bacteria or childlike life on them,
but I most of this,
all this opportunity to seems as far as
we can fail to be largely bed like the
sahara desert and yet we have the
opportunity but the help life flourish
billions of and so like let's quit
squabbling of a.
Some little borders should be drawn one,
one mile to the left or right.
Look up into the skies.
Did you realize,
hey,
you know,
we can do such incredible things and
that's I think why it's really exciting
that yeah,
you and others are connected with some
of the working elon musk is doing
because he's literally going out into
that space,
really exploring our universe and it's
wonderful.
That is exactly why elon musk is so
misunderstood.
Misconstrued him as some kind of
pessimistic doomsayer the region.
He chairs so much about ai safety is
because he more than
almost anyone else appreciates these
amazing opportunities.
It will squander it if we wipe out here
on earth and we're not just going to
wipe out the next generation,
but all generations and this incredible
opportunity that's out there and that
would be really be a waste and ai for
people who think that they'll be better
to do without technology.
Let me just mention that
if we don't improve our technology,
the question isn't whether humanity is
going to go extinct,
questioning whether we're going to get
taken out by the next big asteroid or
the next super volcano or or something
else dumb that we could easily prevent
with more tech.
Right,
and if we want life to flourish
throughout the cosmos,
ai is the key to it.
As I mentioned in a lot of detail in my
book right there,
even many of the most inspired scifi
writers I feel have totally
underestimated the opportunities for
space travel,
especially if the other galaxies,
because they weren't thinking about the
possibility of agi,
which just makes it so much easier.
Right?
Yeah.
So that,
that goes to your,
uh,
view of agi that enables our progress,
said enables a better life.
So that's a beautiful,
that's a beautiful way to put it and
it's something to strive for.
So,
max,
Thank you so much.
Thank you for your time today has been
awesome.
Thank you so much.
Yes.